[Music]
on this monday night the u.s ramps up
the rhetoric against russia
sending more military aid to ukraine and
a message to vladimir putin a sovereign
independent ukraine will be around a lot
longer than vladimir putin a blistering
new report revealing the canadian
military's systemic racism is repulsing
recruits these exclusionary practices
are degrading the recommendations on how
to fix it
billionaire elon musk gets what he wants
he feels like buying tweeter because he
doesn't like something they do his
takeover of twitter and promised to
protect free speech
and a young canadian's historic hot
streak on jeopardy she just pays
attention
matea roach's proud father on her
strategy for success
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
two months since russia launched its war
in ukraine and the united states is now
taking a bolder stand against vladimir
putin not only did the american defense
secretary and secretary of state visit
keeve in person holding talks with the
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
they announced millions more in military
aid saying they believe ukraine can win
with the right equipment and the right
support
in terms of
our their ability to win the first step
in winning is believing that you can win
and so they believe that we can win
we believe that they we can win they can
win
the u.s defense secretary also escalated
the rhetoric towards russia saying the
u.s wants to see russia weaken to the
degree that it can't do the kinds of
things that it has done in invading
ukraine tonight russia's foreign
minister sergey lavrov told russian
media outlets peace talks with ukraine
will continue but he said the danger of
world war iii
is real
redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
this video shot by ukraine's azov
battalion claims to be from underneath
the last holdout in mariupol the azov
style steel plant these women say their
kids haven't seen daylight for six weeks
my country is simply dying says this
woman the children here cry all the time
they want to play they want to live
another attempt to get civilians out of
marijuana failed monday ukraine says it
didn't get security guarantees from
moscow
inside russia this fire at an oil depot
in the western city of priyansk the
cause is unknown but it's not the first
such explosion in russia during the war
briansk is only about 150 kilometers
north of ukraine later monday reports of
another explosion outside of its borders
this time at a government building in
the capital of the breakaway moldovan
region of transnistria the area has been
occupied by russian troops for three
decades last week a russian commander
said he wants russian gains in ukraine
to link up with the region
inside ukraine more deadly rocket
strikes including five targeting
railways trains have been crucial for
ukraine during two months of war
carrying refugees arms and visiting
world leaders
the latest u.s defense secretary lloyd
austin and u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken they met with ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky on sunday mr
president
the world has been inspired by
your courage your commitment your
professionalism austin a former army
commander says he believes ukraine can
win the war contributing another 700
million u.s dollars in military aid
given to ukraine and to nato allies who
are also providing ukraine support we do
know
that a sovereign independent ukraine
will be around a lot longer than
vladimir putin's on the scene washington
has now pumped 3.7 billion us dollars
into the war so they are now committing
to ukraine to help ukraine in far more
advanced ways because they believe
ukraine can win them and maybe force a
peace settlement on ukraine's terms as
much as russia's trucks un secretary
general antonio guterres heads from
turkey to moscow to meet with vladimir
putin tuesday before meeting zielinski
in keeve thursday more in hope than
expectation that peace can be achieved
anytime soon redmond shannon global news
london
there aren't too many people who could
fork out 44 billion dollars to buy a
social media site but for the world's
richest man it is peanuts and elon musk
now owns twitter reaching a deal with
the board today to take it private musk
has more than 80 million followers on
twitter and he has a controversial
reputation about his own conduct on the
site he claims he's going to make it
better than ever abigail beeman reports
on what musk is promising and what his
critics are worried about
first paypal electric cars then space
now elon musk's next frontier social
media he works from from his whims you
know he feels like going to space he
feels like buying twitter because he
doesn't like something they do monday
afternoon twitter announced the deal
will go through elon musk will be the
platform's sole owner for 44 billion
dollars 54 dollars and 20 cents a share
this is a game of high stakes poker and
ultimately the twitter board was waiting
for a second bidder or a white knight to
come they never came well i think it's
very important for
there to be
an inclusive arena for
free speech most of what we know about
the world's richest man's plans for
twitter's future comes from the odd
tweet he wants to defeat the spam bots
he wants his worst critics to stay on
the site and make the algorithms open
source but beyond that i don't think
anyone really knows aside from himself
what he really wants to do there is much
consternation about what may happen when
such a powerful and influential social
media site falls into the hands of just
one person particularly one with a
penchant for being provocative we see
correlations between visiting those
platforms and believing in
misinformation about vaccines or about
election frauds and a lot of important
topics high on the speculation list
would musk allow former u.s president
donald trump or other banned users back
on the site trump told fox news monday
he won't rejoin we've seen where sort of
untrammeled free speech rights brings us
it brings us to
troll farms it brings us to bad actors
it brings us to hate mobs being deployed
against often marginalized people many
women and racialized people do not feel
safe on these platforms many who study
social media and misinformation feel in
general private ownership and a lack of
regulation are not the answers rather
more oversight regulation and education
would help twitter says this deal was
unanimously approved by the board of
directors it's expected to close later
this year pending the approval of
shareholders donna all right abigail
beeman in washington tonight thanks well
one of elon musk's controversial tweets
was support for the so-called freedom
convoy here in canada the federal
government invoked the emergencies act
back in february to end the protests and
blockades that had gone on for weeks now
a public inquiry has been launched into
the use of the act it's led by paul
rouleaux a sitting ontario appeals court
judge and already there are questions
about how much information will be
shared with rouleau and with the public
ross lord reports
even before announcing the inquiry the
government preemptively defended its
decision invoking the emergencies act
was a decision that was taken only after
careful consideration
the public inquiry will be given powers
to summon witnesses under oath and force
them to provide necessary documents it
will examine circumstances that led to
the convoy protests which gridlocked
downtown ottawa for weeks and choked off
traffic at canada u.s border crossings
and it will explore a key question was
the emergencies act a government
overreaction or necessary to restore
order in the nation's capital the act is
only to be used in the event of a
national emergency the act defines a
national emergency as an urgent
temporary and critical situation that
seriously endangers the health and
safety of canadians or seriously
threatens the government's ability to
preserve the sovereignty security and
territorial integrity of canada we are
talking about a very high threshold
whether it's you know espionage violent
extremism
or subversion or
you know other kind of very major
serious threats protest organizers say
the government overreached
at no time
did this convoy in ottawa
meet those standards it was a completely
inappropriate use the government insists
the danger and the damage went far
beyond ottawa the incredible
and devastating
damage that was done to public safety at
ports of entry
in the form of interruption to
trade and travel the interruption to
supply chains the inquiry commissioner
is paul rulo he's spent 20 years as a
judge in ontario in a statement rouleau
says i am committed to ensuring the
process is as open and transparent as
possible but it's unclear if the
government will release cabinet
documents related to its decision mr
speaker that inquiry will be useless
unless they waive cabinet confidence and
allow canadians to know the whole story
the government insists rulo will have
broad powers and access the ability to
compel witnesses and the compel the
production of documents subject as
always to lawful
privileges of evidence that may exist
rule has until next february to report
his findings
ross lord global news
the federal government can and must do
more to fight systemic discrimination
and racism in the canadian armed forces
that is according to a new report
released today it reveals a toxic
environment that the report says could
end up repulsing new recruits and put
canada's national security at risk the
report was done by four former members
of the military and as david aiken
explains they found barriers to equity
and the forces run deep and wide
my name is argianos which means the
place where the sky and the earth come
together derek montour joined the royal
montreal regiment right out of high
school he loved the army life but then
in the summer of 1990
he found himself deployed to oka part of
the army group surrounding his own
mohawk community and that experience
would forever change him team members
who i was with
and who was prepared to lay down my life
with
i would hear them talking about the oka
crisis
and i heard them say i wish we'd all
i'll go in and kill all them savages
montour now a retired sergeant was on
the panel of four ex-military men and
women with advice on how his country can
do better fundamentally that was my hope
is that i could learn the skills on how
to defend my people in a better way the
defense minister vows to do just that we
need to attract more people to our armed
forces and we need an armed forces that
looks like canada there were some pieces
of advice that may be obvious
doing better at weeding out the white
supremacists who wear the uniform or
overhaul the military police a system
rife with conflicts of interest but the
panel came up with lots of less obvious
ideas to address insidious systemic
racism and discrimination change the
menu for example at the military mass
less of the meat and potatoes at the
heart of the white western european diet
more options from other cultures asian
indigenous african
the panelists even recommended
overhauling the chaplain system in the
military the panel advisors argued no
chaplain could be in the armed forces
preaching a religion where black people
were excluded as leaders and the same
logic the panel said
chaplains from religious traditions
where women are excluded from church
leadership should also have no place in
a military trying to erase
discrimination donna
david aiken thanks parts of southern
manitoba are in for a messy cleanup
after being pummeled by a nasty weekend
storm
people are still assessing the damage
including flood damage left behind after
heavy rain snow and powerful winds in
winnipeg between 50 and 70 millimeters
of rain fell and crews are working to
restore power for thousands of people
throughout the region after heavy winds
and thick ice downed power lines
beijing's new covid outbreak coming up
the city's drastic move to curb the
spread to millions plus remembering the
world's oldest person and her secret to
longevity
we are still learning about the
long-term impacts of covid19 especially
on children to get a better sense the
federal government is investing 6.7
million dollars in a national pediatric
research platform the platform is called
pediatric outcome improvement through
coordination of research networks or
popcorn for short it will give 16
research teams a chance to collaborate
on infections vaccination and the social
impacts of the virus
it will support research
research teams at pediatric hospitals
across the country and facilitate
information sharing and for information
use among these sites to ensure a better
and more coordinated research
outcome
of the active reported cases in canada
right now children and youth up to the
age of 19 account for nearly 20 percent
of infections that's about 400 000
people a covid19 outbreak in beijing has
triggered mass testing in the city of 21
million china has a strict zero covet
approach and despite only 70 positive
cases surfacing since friday several
neighborhoods are already under lockdown
including beijing's most populous
district some people are rushing to buy
fresh food and supplies concerned they
will be confined to their homes like the
25 million residents of shanghai
a japanese woman believed to be the
world's oldest person has died at the
age of 119.
kane tadaka was born in 1903. that's the
same year the wright brothers made their
first successful flights she lived her
last years in a nursing home had
survived cancer twice not to mention two
world wars the spanish flu and covid
tanaka had four children and adopted a
fifth her family says she enjoyed
chocolate and fizzy drinks plus solving
math problems and staying curious the
guinness world record says 118 year old
sister andre from france is now the
oldest person alive
relief over re-election ahead why
france's allies are breathing easier
over macron's new
mandate french president emmanuel macron
may have disappointed many french
citizens during his first five years in
office but the alternative right-wing
candidate marine le pen was even less
appealing macron is the first sitting
french president to be re-elected in the
last 20 years he won 58.6 percent of the
votes on the weekend le pen won 41 and a
half percent as eric sorenson reports
the status quo seems to not only suit
many people in france it's widely
supported by the country's allies
it was a resounding victory for emmanuel
macron
though the reaction across much of
france was not one of joy but relief
this man not a macron supporter says at
least she didn't win
she is marine le pen who would have gone
hard right on immigration and likely
weakened ties to nato and the eu had she
won
for many macron represents stability
there is continuity with a president who
is pro-europe and pro-business says this
investment banker but the election
showed a deepening divide in france
macron won the election by 17 points
taking urban centers decisively
including 85 percent of the vote in
paris but le pen won many districts in
the industrial north and made
significant gains in the rural south a
sign as in other western countries that
many voters feel left behind and are
increasingly receptive to hard-line
political ideas
we are the opposition says this le pen
ally as her party prepares now for
parliamentary elections in june what the
french government needs to do and what
all governments to do is try to tackle
the vast increase we've seen inequality
the relief from macron's win was just as
great in many world capitals we'll feel
good about the french election where
there was fear that le pen would take
the pressure off vladimir putin and
russia in the war against ukraine the
unity of nato uh has been absolutely
vital for the uh stance we've taken
against uh putin and uh that will now
continue i'm very very reassured by that
indeed putin's invasion may
inadvertently be helping democratic
political parties across europe
in slovenia an environmentalist upset
the country's right-wing president in
another election yesterday one can hope
that the results in slovenia
and in
paris mean that populism has reached its
peak in decline and if so we have to
thank
putin who's helped kill it randall
hansen says putin would very much have
wanted le pen to win in france in the
end putin's attack on ukraine may have
helped defeat her and re-elect emmanuel
macron eric sorensen global news toronto
next she's still at it we talked to the
father of canada's jeopardy champ about
her knack for trivia
that splashdown wraps the first american
privately funded mission to the
international space station funded by
houston-based axiom space the spacex
crew dragon capsule landed a week later
than expected because of bad weather the
team which includes a canadian investor
spent 15 days on the iss doing research
for multiple organizations their voyage
is viewed as a milestone for
commercializing the cosmos
another canadian continues to make
history down here on earth matea roach
who grew up in halifax has now won 14
games straight on jeopardy that's the
longest streak any canadian has pulled
off on the popular quiz show as mike
drewlay reports a knack for trivia and a
love of listening might be her secret
sauce
no matter what happens in today's game
mateo roach is going to have a pretty
good weekend
you think ken with her 14th win mateo
roach now has the eighth longest streak
in jeopardy's 38th season history which
she's done by being correct on 92 of her
answers who are the chicago bulls what
is midgard what are nunchucks right back
home in halifax the roach family is
getting set to host their 15th watch
party where they'll eat jeopardy cookies
and matea's dad phil will reminisce
about the last time he won a trivia
pursuit
when she was 15.
christmas time or the next time she she
comes home if we bring out the trivial
pursuit i i'd like i'm down for it you
never back away from a challenge right i
don't care how bad i get smashed and he
knows that will happen because matea he
says has always been a sponge when it
comes to information she just pays
attention it's surprising how much you
can learn talking to friends or you know
schoolmates and so forth if you're truly
engaged in the conversation she's
certainly paying attention now and is
also waiting to be paid 320 000 u.s
and counting
along the way she's laughed at jokes
about her nationality a country known
for its mounties moose maple syrup while
showing her personality discussing what
she silently mouths before every game so
you can take the girl out of catholic
school but you cannot take the catholic
school out of the girl and so i'm saying
hail mary's
when her run is finally over because
everybody loses eventually her dad says
it will be interesting to see how being
a jeopardy champion impacts her life her
plan prior to jeopardy was to to go to
law school hopefully this fall
still waiting to hear back from
universities if anyone is listening
and
if it will change that trajectory we
don't know that's the future what does
the now hold what is a jeopardy cookie
in game number fifteen mike drolie
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is wild pacific trail in euclid
bc home of the amphitrite point
lighthouse we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]